In the last few weeks I've gotten requests
on doing videos on entrepreneurship having
to do with family, how to run a business with
family, what it means to be married to an
entrepreneur, how is an entrepreneur supposed
to be before you date someone who's an entrepreneur.
All of these things that I've put together
because you requested them and today I decided
to do an episode dedicated to mothers.
Why I believe most mothers would make very
good entrepreneurs.
This is from pure experience.
I've mentored a lot of different people.
I've mentored single fathers, single mothers,
husbands and wives, ladies by themselves,
mothers by themselves, and I can see certain
strengths mothers have that helps them in
their business.
You've got to always know and lead with the
strengths that you have in business, and I
think these are the strengths that mothers
have that you need to tap into this to help
and leverage your business to grow even faster
and excel.
Let me get right into it.
I came up with 14 of them -- I'm sure there's
more, but I came up with 14 of them that I
feel are particular to moms.
So let's start off with the first one.
They tend to deliver bad news gently.
There's something about the way a mother delivers
bad news.
They're a little more tender about it.
They're a little bit more understanding about
it.
They are more concerned about the other person's
feelings on when they want to tell them "here's
what happened, here's what happened, here's
what happened," where the other person's taking
it better vs. a father may say, "It doesn't
matter.
. . here's what you need to do.
" And it's boom.
And the kid goes in his room.
They have some feelings as well.
Mothers are better at dealing with that than
fathers.
That's a strength of yours when it comes to
dealing with business.
Second, they have natural leadership instincts.
I think mothers have a very sixth sense.
They know things that are going on that maybe
nobody else knows what's going on.
They have leadership instincts.
They can feel.
One of the reasons they have such an edge
is that mothers tend to spend more time with
kids then fathers do and when you spend more
time with kids -- this is not in all cases
-- but when you spend more time with kids,
kids are all emotional.
So your sensitivity toward emotion goes even
higher than a man would or a father would
because you're around it more.
Kids are very good teachers.
So can you imagine if kids are very good teachers,
mothers are getting more teaching from kids
than fathers are because kids teach us about
emotions and feelings.
So your natural ability to be able to read
people is much better.
This is why a lot of times a mother says,
"I don't get a good feeling about that person
or I don't get a good feeling about this."
They have a certain intuition because they
see it with their kids all the time.
So you have natural leadership instinct.
Point number three would be, you're not afraid
to speak your mind.
I think mothers will approach problems and
say, "Son, I don't like how you're handling
this."
"Honey, I don't like how this is taking place.
I don't like the way we did this.
I don't know if we're doing the right thing
here."
Mothers will generally say this.
Fathers may set aside the problems and just
go and say, "I'll figure it out."
Mothers will bring it up.
They're naturally not afraid to speak their
mind.
In business, it helps you a lot to talk about
the things that are taking place in business
and it helps resolve issues sooner rather
than delaying an issue that's going to take
place that we have to resolve 7 months from
now.
Mothers do it now.
Next, typically, and this is kind of a strange
way of describing it, (men, we can learn a
lot from this), but mothers typically have
other mothers that they confide in and they
talk about their problems.
So they have natural mentors, other people
that they talk to that are in the same situation
as them.
This allows them to release a certain frustration
that they're having as a mother raising her
kids, as you see someone else who is going
through it as well.
So if you use that same ability and find other
entrepreneurs to confide in who are in a similar
situation as you, to understand you, and those
who overcome -- not those that necessarily
want to say, "this is why we can't run a business."
I'm not talking about that.
Just because you're a mother, doesn't make
you a great entrepreneur.
Let's get that part open.
I'm not trying to be diplomatic here.
I'm just telling you that just because someone's
a mother doesn't mean she'll make a great
entrepreneur.
There are still negative and positive mothers.
I'm talking about somebody who is positive,
that is truly wanting to build a business.
If you tap into that same ability to confide
in your peers to find that the situation there
and you do the same in business and find a
mentor, you'll generally find a way to solve
that problem or overcome that issue that you're
addressing at that time.
Next is urgency.
Entrepreneurs are urgent.
The reason they're urgent is because they
have so many things going on -- drop off the
kids, pick up the food, boom, job, school,
music.
. . You have so many things -- here's what
I've got.
10 minutes, 15 minute call, there's a certain
level of urgency when you're dealing with
mothers because there's only 24 hours in a
day and there's so many things that need to
get done.
Somehow, some way, they tend to get more things
done, mothers do, as entrepreneurs.
The next thing is natural networking skills.
I would say moms are very good at asking,
"Who do you know that does this, who do you
know that does that, who do you know this.
. .?" Men, we tend to kind of think we know
it all, we tend to think we don't need help,
so networking wise, they don't mind asking
anybody who they know in this area, so they're
very good when it comes to asking for referrals.
My gosh, I've had sales people in our company,
54% of the agents in our company are ladies.
And those who are some of the best producers
in our company are mothers who are very good
at working the referral market.
And the referral market is "who do you know?"
And that comes from natural networking skills
that you already have in place to use and
apply.
Remember, a lot of these things I may be saying
right now, and you're a mother watching this
and you're saying, "How come I don't use that
skill?"
You've got to use it for it to work!
You have the muscle -- it's almost like you
have that weapon in your arsenal, and if you're
not using it in business, it won't do anything
for you.
You have to take these things and actually
apply them and you'll realize how simple it
is because you've been doing it all your life
already.
Point #7 is there's a certain level of trustworthiness,
for mothers.
There's a certain level of trust.
I don't know how to describe this.
You know, if someone is selling me something
and they're a mother and they have kids, I
can tell you myself as a buyer, I trust.
Because for me, I always think a mother is
going to give the right feedback because she
has a kid and she knows she doesn't want anyone
to take advantage of her kids so probably
she's not going to want to take advantage
of me.
So in my mind, as a person, I trust a mother's
selling in the area of business when it comes
down to wanting to buy their product.
The next one is emotions.
Tenderhearted.
It goes back to when I told you they deliver
bad news better, but this is more about the
listening side.
When I say emotions, they make better listeners.
So if a client wants to buy something, and
let's just say they sit there and say, "Well,
you know, let me tell you my experience with
the last person."
"Tell me about it."
Well, the last person I dealt with, he did
this, he did this, he did this, he did that."
"How did that make you feel?"
"It made me feel this way."
"What do you think about that?
What do you think about that John?
What do you think about that Mary?
What are some things you'd want to be different
when you do business with somebody new?"
They're very good at displaying listening
skills, to hearing you out.
Men just want to give the next big positive,
popular answer to be impressive and say, "Did
you hear that comeback I gave?!"
Sometimes we forget, we don't even know that.
But mothers are very good at saying, "Okay,
I'm hearing you out" and we like to be heard
out, and as a customer we want to talk to
somebody that's listening to our issues and
our challenges, and hopefully they'll figure
out a way to resolve it, if we trust.
Which in a sense like this, we would because
we're dealing with a mother that's got a higher
trusting rate than the rest.
Next, they ask a lot of questions.
Point #9, you know, when a kid comes home
from school.
. . practice again.
When they're picked up, "How was school?
What did you learn today?
What did that guy say?
What did that girl say?
What's that girl's name?
What does that girl do?
Who's your best friend?
Are you hanging out with that guy?" They want
to know everything, right?
Think about it!
Oh my God, my mom asked me all the questions
on the drive home, and I know what she's trying
to ask me.
They're trying to figure out clues, right?
So why is she hanging out?
When I picked her up, she was talking to this
guy.
"So tell me about that guy.
I like your friend."
She was talking to that other guy and that
other guy's a senior and her daughter's a
freshman.
"I noticed you were talking.
Is that the football player?
Is he the quarterback?
Good looking guy.
Tell me about him.
How many times have you guys hung out?"
Mom's trying to find out if there's anything
going on with that quarterback and the daughter.
It's the same exact thing in sales or in business.
A mother asks questions to get to the issue
of resolving to see if this may be a problem
that they have to overcome later on when it
comes to asking for a check or asking for
the sale.
I'm going to resolve this right now is what
I need to do when it comes to asking questions.
No matter what happens -- office situations,
environment, leadership, it all comes down
to the questions you're asking the people
you're dealing with.
So mothers, because they ask very good questions,
they also make very, very good negotiators.
Point #10: They make very, very good negotiators.
They negotiate with their kids, they negotiate
with their husbands, they have to get the
husbands to be willing to pay for something,
they have to be getting the families to settle
and come together, they have to be willing
to put a birthday party where the in-laws
don't want to get together with the other
in-laws and there's negotiation going on with
the in-laws and she's in the middle trying
to get both parties to work -- there's so
much negotiation going on with mothers that
-- there's a lot of skills that you have that
there's not a price tag to put on there because
you didn't go to university to learn it for
$200,000.
It's the life university that mothers go through.
But you've got to use those skills.
You've got to use those skills for business
to see the results.
Point #11: They are superior multi-taskers.
There's not a debate here to say whether multi-tasking
is real or not.
I've done a video on that.
If you want to debate that, go watch that
video.
Mothers are better multi-taskers.
They hold the baby, they cook, and they talk
to the husband simultaneously.
Three actions going on at the same time.
They are better multi-taskers.
And sometimes in business, you're going to
be doing multi-tasking.
#12: Better problem solvers.
They solve problems very well.
Again, the practice they get on solving problems
on who?
Kids!
It's constant problems that they're facing
with kids, so they have to become better problem
solvers because they're getting practice non-stop
with their kids already.
#13: Tolerance for pain.
I had to write this down because my wife's
had two kids and she has one on the way and
I've been part of both of those deliveries
and I see some of the things mothers go through.
Your tolerance for pain is unreal.
There's a reason why you were chosen to be
a mother, a woman.
If you have a child, there's a reason you
are where you are with that.
You've got to know there's a reason for that.
Your tolerance for pain, when it comes to
business -- I once heard a lady who owned
a business and raised kids.
And she started a startup, and she lost a
couple of startups and one of them worked.
She said, "The closest thing a man will ever
experience to giving birth to a baby is starting
a new company."
And I sat there and said, "That's pretty interesting
because it's painful to start a business sometimes,
because you're going through having to learn
so much all at the same time, but because
mothers have a tolerance for pain, they're
able to channel that into business and they
can leverage that, and use it as an upper
hand for themselves.
Point # 14 is event planning.
You're generally better event planners -- weddings,
birthdays, you have so much practice doing
that, that when it comes down to business
events, putting events together, for business,
you have an upper hand, you have a very big
upper hand, and in business it's all about
putting nice events together, networking,
taking care of people, hosting good events.
When you put good events with charities and
whether it's profit or cigar or wine or parties
-- all these types of things, this is when
people come and ask, "who hosted this event?"Such
and such did.
She put the event together?
Then everyone goes to her as a referral.
You're a better event planner in business
and that helps you out a lot when it comes
to the business side.
Lastly, mothers tend to unite people.
Mothers bring kids together.
Mothers tend to bring families together.
Mothers tend to keep the siblings together.
Mothers tend to keep the son and the father
close together.
Mothers tend to -- when one of the kids is
going through issues, relationships with their
spouse, they tend to want to keep them together.
They have a strength of unity and uniting
people.
That helps you in business because in business,
say a vendor and you don't get along.
They can bring you together and figure out
a way to say, "What are you not happy about?
What is the number you want?
We can't pay over this.
What can we do about this?
Can we make this work?
We like you, you like us, we've been together
for awhile, why don't we just try to make
this work?
Great, you want our business, right?
Yes, we want your business.
We've been together for 11 years.
Do we really want to make this relationship
be sour over one simple sale that we don't
agree over $1,000?
No.
Why don't we make it work?
So unite.
There's a strength in doing that.
So you got 15 things.
Now there's a lot more, and I'd love to hear
from you if you want to post it on the bottom
and comment and let us know what I've missed
here.
But I can tell you one thing here.
If you watch this and you're not a mother,
but you know other people who are entrepreneurs
and they're mothers, share this video with
them.
On behalf of Mother's Day, send them a Happy
Mother's Day.
And know that for me, I look for mothers that
I do business with and I see their strengths
in business.
They're incredible because they have certain
skill sets that others don't have and I need
to bring it out in them and show it to them
that they have this ability already.
Let's put it to use.
You've been doing this for the last 9 years
with your three kids, let's put this to use.
You've been using these things for the last
17 years, you already know how to do this,
why aren't you doing this in business?
Let's put that to use.
So on behalf of all the mothers that also
follow Valuetainment -- and I get lots of
nice messages from you -- and we did a survey
the other day, and I listened to a lot of
the comments that the mothers sent on the
survey that we did.
And we definitely want to let you know that
I'm thankful for you as well, and I am who
I am as well because I had a single mother
that raised me at some period as well and
there's some impact that was made on my life
-- a tremendous impact made on my life.
And I want to give some love to all the mothers
out there who are entrepreneurs.
Go out there and use your strengths to your
advantage so you can succeed as an entrepreneur
as well.
And if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please be sure to do so on the bottom here.
If you're watching this video somewhere else,
on a different website, visit patrickbetdavid.com.
Thank you.